[Music]
all right new and new today it has been
a deadly year on our roadways traffic
fatalities are up at least 30 percent
statewide compared to the same time last
year
safety advocates want you to pay
attention to their message as they work
to put an
end to this alarming trend we report
this unfortunately it seems every day
hector mejia live at umc trauma center
with what you need to know hi hector
hey there and advocates say it's
everyone's responsibility to make sure
we make it home
safely not just the drivers and a group
got together here earlier this morning
inside university medical center this is
where trauma patients get seen after a
crash
it's also nevada's only pediatric trauma
center
unlv's vulnerable road users project
brought together
law enforcement agencies along with
doctors to talk about the recent traffic
fatalities
monday night two-year-old miguel angel
morales was killed by an suv
while crossing the road in the northeast
valley in the first
in the five weeks since may 1st at least
20 people died on our roadways in clark
county more than half
were pedestrians motorcyclists cyclists
and moped riders also part of the
tragedy
this morning we heard from people who
see this firsthand
almost on a daily basis
while it is very sad to see injured
adults
and adults that die you can only imagine
what it's like to see children die and
to talk with their parents
that they have lost their loved one who
should have had a normal long life
every patient i see woke up in the
morning
and thought it was going to be a normal
day
it's very sad to hear and dr debra cole
says pleading to parents
please restrain your child with a
seatbelt or car seat when they're in the
car with you
also if you're on a bicycle or
motorcycle please remember to wear your
helmet
we also heard from metro's fatal detail
they said during the first
six months of this year they've worked
on 59 fatalities
last year that number was only 41 the
top causes are impairment
and speeding reporting outside umc
hector mejia
8 news now